[Music]
[Applause]
that model this is a twelve inspector
the object
today
[Music]
so the grooves on this record are a
little different than a regular vinyl
record each groove is about ten times
wider and ten times deeper than a normal
record you can't really fit quite as
much audio on each side as you would a
normal record you can fit about five or
six minutes of recording so you ready
these 3d files of these records are very
high resolution just for this minute of
audio on here this is a 200 megabyte
file it's made up of about four million
of these little triangles kind of like
all arranged in 3d space to create this
3d model these records are pretty sturdy
it's not really up to worry too much
about like damaging them just let the
water kind of evaporate so I'm from
Seattle so I printed out Nirvana smells
like teen spirit
[Music]
we actually played this record in our
office and somebody got out their phone
and was running one of those apps that
can recognize songs and I totally picked
this up so that was really cool this is
this is Daft Punk around the world I'm
still working this kind of work in
progress it sounds really good in the
beginning as soon as the bass drum
starts kicking in it's actually so funky
and so kind of hard hitting that it's
been throwing the needle and often
causing it to skip around so I'm kind of
it's caused me to like revise my
algorithm a little bit but I think I'm
going to be able to get a good this is
what this is my original thing that I
start with this is Pixies debaser this
is the first song that I printed and it
was what I used to kind of optimize
my program and really good
the signal-to-noise
[Music]